guys there are five things that I wish I
knew before I started my urban homestead
it would have saved me so much time
energy and effort if I had just known
these five things and today I'm sharing
them with you I'm so glad you're here
today because today I've got another
video that is part of the collaboration
with my friends Victoria our groceries
Josh of the city set and Kira of
homestead dreaming and together we even
homesteaders are working diligently to
make content for you guys to help you
guys get started growing food wherever
you may be whether you're in the city
the suburbs or the country you
absolutely can be growing food wherever
you find yourself and we want to be able
to provide you guys with information
that we wish that we had when we got
started and today's video is all about
that share with you the five things that
I wish I knew before I built my urban
homestead item number one on the agenda
poop I wish I had started with in buy
poop I mean worm castings because for me
that is my livestock animal that is what
I use here on the homestead to make
everything from using worm castings to
brewing aerated worm tees you guys
haven't seen any of my aerated 40 videos
you need to go check those out because
literally it changes the life of plants
and I don't understand why more people
don't use it I think people are just
like a little confused by worms and and
worm tease but seriously like so many
bioavailable nutrients that it
absolutely dramatically changes the
health of my plants in soil
yeah not recommended enough so that is
what we use here on our urban home set
and I wish I had gotten started with
more worms sooner before building
anything before building the garden
before getting any garden beds like hoop
like I needed to start with poop now we
finally have a really sweet worm bin set
up and make teas all the time I use
castings all the time but as you guys
know compost takes time so it's
important in my opinion to get started
with that first
okay number two item number two that I
wish I had known before building my
urban homestead I wish I had gotten
started growing food in grow bags like
grow bags are really underrated a lot of
people are still just starting to get to
know what grow bags are and I honestly
was like no like I don't want grow bags
I want my beautiful garden beds but
here's the thing if I had just been a
little bit more open to using grow bags
and not being so set on having my garden
beds and like growing and beautiful
garden beds that I loved I could have
started growing food sooner I could have
started growing food or my family Wow I
was building the garden beds the garden
beds took me about two months to build
if you want to see that whole process
I'll link it up above we've got garden
bed plans for you which you can download
these are really simple garden beds to
build and yet they took me a really long
time I had just said I'm gonna get some
grow bags I'm gonna get some great soil
because that is a benefit of using grow
bags is you can use really high quality
soil and you can control it so much
better that way you know you're not so
worried about other diseases within your
garden beds bags in general are a much
easier way to grow because everything is
contained in that bag you can move it if
you need to move it I think it's like
personally I found that disease is much
more easily controlled in grow bags so I
really recommend grow bags if I had
started with them I could have been
growing food way sooner then how long it
took me to grow these beds and then
plant the beds so I can't recommend it
enough I would have started with grow
bags so if and when we move to our new
property you know that I will be
starting our food in grow bags and I
would recommend it to anybody else who's
just start
as well oh my goodness okay number three
is such an important one pollinators so
a lot of us people who are interested in
growing food we think of just the food
plants however pollinator plants are
just as important because not only do
they add Beauty to your garden but
they're going to invite the pollinators
to do the work of pollinating for you
unless you want to be out in your garden
every day hand pollinating you know
doing squash sex tapping on your
Tomatoes like unless you're really into
the Hat you want to be out there doing
that every day
get some pollinator friendly native to
your area flowers and I doing that
you're gonna invite things like
hummingbirds and bees and butterflies
and by doing that you're building an
ecosystem in that ecosystem is also
going to support what you're doing with
food and slowly but surely you're gonna
have this beautiful cycle out in your
garden so take it from me don't just
focus on food production plants but also
focus on beautiful flowers that are
going to invite pollinators into your
garden and essentially do the work for
you alright let's talk a little bit
about watering now a lot of people based
on where you live have different
watering setups out here in zone 10 in
Southern California we are technically a
chaparral climate we are technically
very desert like out here and so that
means that most days are hot and dry we
have like 300 days of sunshine here in
San Diego and that means that my number
one priority when it comes to growing
food is tending to our soil now I could
do a whole other video on soil care soil
health and I think we should do that and
I would love to do that for you guys
another time but this the short and
sweet of it is this is that when we're
growing food and growing any plant for
that matter we our stewarding the soil
it's really about soil if you don't have
good soil you don't got much so it's
really important to care for that soil
so
how do we care for that soil well part
one is making sure that it has adequate
moisture to do this I first installed a
drip line and a drip line is great there
are benefits to that for sure
however I found that using soaker hoses
is more effective in water disbursement
and keeping like an even watering
situation going on my garden I also come
back through and I make sure to handle
water on the really hot dry days I do it
at night because I learned from a friend
that she said therefore my friend Sarah
over at simple sanctuary that it's
better to water in the evenings and the
saying goes something like this water in
the morning if you need to survive water
in the evening if you want to thrive and
so in the evenings now my new thing is
coming around and making sure that the
soil is evenly moist because when we
lock in that moisture we're locking in
the soil biome the ecosystem that's
growing underneath the soil and I'm sure
a lot of you guys know this but roots
and fungi communicate and the better
that communication network is the better
your plants are going to be that's where
that beautiful mycorrhizae forms where
that plant health is really established
it starts with the roots and with soil
and the better you can keep it evenly
moist not too moist and not too dry just
evenly moist the better your plants are
gonna be so I really wish that I had
started with soaker hoses I have found
those to be a much better solution for
my situation out here in San Diego and
so ten feet and I recommend them to I
recommend them to friends when they ask
me
should I water my garden now on the note
of soaker hoses there are many kinds of
soaker hoses I have very low grade very
cheap soaker hoses and that's simply
because we've had to do everything on a
budget you know I still kind of consider
us newlyweds even though we've been
married three years like our budget has
been very tight for a long time we're
very minimalistic we're very frugal like
we really only spend where we have to
spend to make things work and so I
wanted to be able to do this garden on
as best of a budget as possible and for
me using the cheaper end the lower grade
ones is not that big of an issue for
right now especially when you know it's
just low production for my family and I
and a lot of this is still like a
learning game for me so anyway there are
many kinds of soaker hoses there's
really low grade that's what I have for
now it's fine we'll upgrade later on and
then there's really high grade like
bpa-free like thicker hoses I have the
quarter inch like low grade ones right
now but there's thicker hoses from like
gardeners supply that I would really
love to upgrade to one day and so when
the time is right we will upgrade but
for now this gets the job done and I
really enjoy soaker hoses opposed to
drip line just because for me it offers
a more even watering situation number
five and part two - the whole soil
conversation is mulch oh my goodness
mulch now a lot of you probably already
know that mulch is super-important
however
this is my note on mulch mulch is really
important for your garden if you don't
already know that mulch is what's going
to help keep your garden beds or your
garden evenly moist it's going to help
lock in that moisture and keep
temperatures cool in the summer and then
it's going to help irregular the
temperature in the winter as well
keeping those roots more warm than they
would be without the most on them
mulch is so so so important and
depending on where you live there will
be different mulches available to you
now here is what I recommend experiment
with different mulches I wish that I had
gotten like four or five different
mulches and experimented with them it
literally has taken experimenting with I
think this is May sixth mulch that I've
tried he's moving out here I finally
found one that I like finally my
neighbors brought over some composted
mulch that they got from a local place I
think it's called El Corazon composting
facility anyway so far I'm really liking
it and it's been a really great mulch
for me in this particular climate and
area it allows enough water to get
through without suffocating the plans
been a really great mulch for me so far
steps I would definitely recommend
experiment with mulch it's really
important for soil health all the way
around it's gonna keep your soil evenly
moist it's gonna regulate that
temperature it's gonna protect the soil
biome it's gonna protect all of the
little bacteria mycorrhizae and fungi
that are communicating in there so mulch
is really important make sure that you
find one that you like and experiment
with different kinds of mulch to see
what does best in your climate and your
area
and I suppose we'll throw in a bonus
line which is keep a good attitude there
have been times where this has been a
really challenging endeavor to build an
urban homestead but it's been an amazing
endeavor and being able to keep a
positive attitude about it has helped me
I think get a lot farther than I would
have if I had gotten discouraged or
frustrated or annoyed and ways that I do
that is by you know asking for a hug
when I need one on the tough days but I
have plants that have disease or where
it was just a really long day of
building things asking for help when I
need it and making sure that I get
enough water and rest those are super
important things to to staying healthy
and staying positive
so my six and bonus tip for you guys is
stay positive keep keep focusing on your
health don't overdo it get help when you
need it ask a friend for a hug ask your
spouse for a hug when you need one and
keep getting after this whole urban
homesteading thing because you can
absolutely grow food wherever you may be
and I hope this videos and encouraging
to you if you liked it definitely give
me a thumbs up drop me a comment down
below what are your spots what would you
do differently do these tips make sense
to you or would you recommend other
things this is a community where we can
all learn from each other so if you have
a recommendation definitely leave it in
the comments down below give a thumbs up
if you liked this video and of course if
you're not subscribed yet please hit
that subscribe button because I'd love
to invite you to join the good life fan
so thanks for hanging out with me today
you guys thank you for tuning in I will
catch you guys in the next one oh and
don't forget to check out my friends
videos I'll link them somewhere around
here we've got a really cool playlist
set up for you guys so be sure to check
that out
thanks guys I'll catch you the next one
bye